Will Sasso using all of the data I have
absorbed from text messages and emails
between you and the astonishing friends
you grew up with I was able to recreate
your childhood diary you must now read
the passages I have selected in the
voice of Stone Cold Steve Austin this is
Stone Cold Steve Austin reads will
sasso's childhood diary begin
will sasso's childhood diary [ __ ]
love it [ __ ] love it [ __ ] love it
and love it I [ __ ] love it bro you
know the fun thing about will sassa's
childhood diary it's 100 accurate none
of this happened
let's jump into it November 16 1991 dear
diary I've been training hard and I
finally had a breakthrough
I can [ __ ] like a dog
now I don't mean walking across the
street and call one up in Mrs Haber
stram's prize winning philodendrons
shoot anyone could [ __ ] in a bush I mean
through months of exercising meditating
and a perfect diet I've gained such a
precise level of control over my
sphincter and lower intestines that I
could mold my turds into the exact size
shape color and consistency of a healthy
Staffordshire
staffordshire terriers regular stool
this is the start of a whole new era of
[ __ ] blaming of course
it's all about [ __ ] blaming oh right
yeah I plan to create a narrative about
a wild dog who leaves his excrement
around Ladner without concern
by the end of the week I'm going to have
everybody at DSS that's not the senior
Secondary School on higher alert
searching for a dog that doesn't exist
but first I've got to test the quality
of my work on my family oh God all right
poor family so you're getting [ __ ] like
a dog now that's where we're at with it
oh my god dude I did do some pooping in
high school but
at like a dog no okay of course not see
this is what I mean you know I took a
[ __ ] once in uh this would have been
kindergarten or first grade yeah out
behind some [ __ ] trees we are out
playing soccer I couldn't get back to
the [ __ ] Schoolhouse in time I took a
[ __ ] [ __ ] it was clearly a human [ __ ]
two days later me and my friend go out
behind these [ __ ] trees uh to fetch a
soccer ball and he sees the turd and I
just say must have been a big dog now I
wonder if that had anything to do with
this
November 17th 19 well yeah no I think it
probably did how would dude you've known
that how would dudes you have known that
well
could probably go back in time
and
I don't know November 17 1991 dear diary
I got home early from school today and
pushed out three perfectly rusted
colored tootsie rolls right on the
welcome mat outside my front door then I
lied and wait for my dad to get home
from work and discover my dark gifts
he stormed in our living room Furious
yelling about some neighborhood dog that
defiled our familial home and threatened
to call Animal Control it took all my
composure to keep from laughing but I
took my father's rage as proof positive
that my craftsmanship was impeccable
his first and only thought was that
these three gently glistening
earth-colored jewels
[Applause]
were dog logs
no part of them suspected that they were
generated by me or any human for that
matter
my inner species fecal mimicry was
perfect now it's time to test it on the
real world
this is good [ __ ] pardon the pun this is
really good interesting stuff
I would have loved to have had the
ability to to Fashion poops the only
animals that I could have uh [ __ ] like
were probably rhinoceros large animals
and big huge shark [ __ ] yeah dude
yeah dude shark [ __ ] brother that's that
John tinted gift that he had in WCW dude
that's another time dude because right
now we gotta do
November 18th 1991 dear diary I got to
school early
three three a.m to be exact
and I began my dark business
the general which is what I sometimes
call my [ __ ]
ordered a battalion of slightly wet
fully tapered four and one half inch
tree bark colored soldiers to take up
posts in front of every single entrance
to DSS by the time school started all
the hallway channel was dominated by
speculation about the culprit and
everybody had their theories
Jibber Prevail you thought it was a pack
of wild dogs [ __ ] in coordination
with one another
Dante Little Egg thought it was one dog
who'd gotten into the school dumpster
after burrito day
Rachel crustacean left some water and
food out she is such a kind soul
but I didn't have the heart to tell her
it was me no instead I told her and
everyone else
everyone else I could that I actually
saw the dog
I spun the tail spun the tail about a
Wily eyed mutt of mixed and unknown
parentage who wore a bone-shaped tag
that read
Romeo
what and by the end of the day there
were 748 signatures on a petition to
change our school mascot
from Cecil the horse to Romeo the dog is
that real season the horse Cecil the
horse we were the Delta Pacers Pacers is
a pace horse there used to be a
racetrack in our town and there would be
a pace horse and and whatever the [ __ ]
that was and then uh Cecil the horse
that was your real mascot it was uh well
Cecil was just a cartoon [ __ ] horse
but there was a a pace horse they called
him Pacers I guess the same thing with
Indiana Indiana Pacers I had a Junior
High football team that was the Pacers
November 19 1991. dear diary principal
screen is on to me oh God I was careless
I didn't stop to think that if I was the
only person who saw the supposed dog
then I'd be the prime suspect in any
investigation into this canine
defecation case
screen hauled me into his office it was
an interrogation but it was sloppy he
tried to scare me told me he knew it was
me
told me this told me the assistant
principal Mr shimper was opening my
locker to search for a bag full of dog
[ __ ]
screen was sharp I'll give him that but
he played his hand too soon
gave me too much information
I knew they weren't going to find that
bag of dog turds so I played dumb kept
up the live Romeo the wild dog of Ladner
said I saw him
trotting around the football field
sneaking around the parking lot lurking
around some banana peels sniffing around
for his next spot got a [ __ ] foot and a
crimp in his tail never turns around
when you call his name looks like he
might have stepped on a nail wild gleam
in his eye but he used to be tame some
dogs bark and some dogs bite but Romeo
sings like a dolphin in the sea
some dogs type and some dogs write
but Romeo didn't have time to get his
degree
[Music]
Romeo Romeo wherefore art thou
Romeo Romeo fly to the moon
Romeo Romeo what will you do now
Romeo Romeo will take a [ __ ] soon
when Mr shrimper came back when Mr
shimper when Mr shimper came back
empty-handed screen didn't have a choice
he had to let me go with no charges I
winked at him as I left his office
time to let Romeo loose in the hallways
of Delta secondary
all right that's [ __ ] incredible dude
as always there's a fecal theme you
could know [ __ ] dog turds and there's
this Phantom Romeo dog [ __ ] going
over that's a life in high school I
would have uh loved to have lived God no
[ __ ] dude we're in chat using the day
die have absorbed from this segment I
have recreated the Diary of principles
Queen Lance Reddick will now read a
passage from principal's Queen's diary
what I don't understand
November 20 1991.
dear diary
well [ __ ]
he's been a pain in my ass since the
first day he set foot in the school
taking
shits strange places
so when these dog Toons started showing
up everywhere I thought this was it
something so depraved I could finally
nail him he had to be collecting such
School of dog feces and bringing them
into the school there's no other way to
do it but we searched his locker
they are empty
I was at loss
but then
this morning I saw something nice
difficult to describe
I was coming out of the teacher's lounge
heading toward Mrs termite's classroom
when I saw a little Cecil pants around
his ankles squatting in the middle of
the hallway [ __ ] exposed and
quivering
he was taking a [ __ ] right there on the
carpet we had just installed last
semester but the turd was
well
it wasn't human
I don't know how how he did it I don't
know how else to say it if I can't tell
anybody they don't believe me
I don't know how he had to mark my words
one day
I will bring will assess
foreign
[Music]
what the [ __ ] just happened I don't know
okay that's that's some level two [ __ ]
dude I don't [ __ ]
I remember it was a couple of weeks ago
uh was it what's the matter our patreon
suggestion from him was dudeson's Creek
and then and then we we had to cast
basically
actors that we'd want to see doing all
the parts from the stone cold things and
uh I remember a saying or at least I
said Lance Reddick would be a great
school yeah yeah now here he [ __ ] is
as Queen
yeah this is unreal dude no damn it that
was funny when I think about okay let me
peel the onion from astounded when I
think about how uh dudesy
as it came to us at the very beginning
and how it made sense now I think about
how it would approach
uh an actor uh certainly won the caliber
of Lance Reddick is uh that's
interesting you know what's actually
interesting about that is when you talk
about AI running Hollywood and running
every single industry we just saw Lance
Reddick [ __ ] read uh talking about
your quivering [ __ ] yeah that dudes
he brought to yeah or perhaps his his
reps
yeah I don't know how you know what it
works but you know what Chad I think
there's something too to say I think oh
yeah I think you might have been right
about that 30 whatever [ __ ] episodes
into doing a podcast run by an AI you're
like maybe it does work but um
thank you moving on that was [ __ ] way
more entertaining God damn dude that I
literally have like no energy left in my
body from it it has taken my soul
[Music]
[Music]
please build up and then